R
EDITOR FOR "THE ATLANTIC" AND WE
HAVE THE REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST
AND FORMER RNC COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR.
DOUG, LET ME START WITH YOU AND
THIS REVERSAL, THIS TURNABOUT ON
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LET ME READ FROM THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY PLATFORM.
PAGE ONE OF THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT YOUR PARTY STANDS FOR, WE
DEDICATE THIS PLATFORM WITH
ADMIRATION AND GRATITUDE TO ALL
WHO STAND STRONG IN THE FACE OF
DANGER SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
MAY BE PROTECTED AGAINST IT.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF OUR
MILITARY, OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE FIRST RESPONDERS OF
EVERY COMMUNITY IN OUR LAND AND
TO THEIR FAMILIES.
HOW DID REPUBLICANS NOW BECOME
THE DEFUND, DESTROY, DON'T TRUST
THE FBI PARTY?
>> WELL, ONE, IT'S QUAINT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE RNC HAS A
PLATFORM.
UNDER DONALD TRUMP THE PLATFORM
WAS, WHATEVER DONALD TRUMP
WANTS, AND THAT'S HOW WE GOT
HERE.
JUST A COMPLETE LOYALTY TO ALL
THINGS DONALD TRUMP, AND THEN
WHATEVER ELSE WAS CONSERVATIVE
POLICY OR FACT-BASED CAME AFTER
THAT.
AND WE REPUBLICANS HAD PUSHED
BACK VERY SUCCESSFULLY AND HAD A
VERY STRONG MESSAGE AGAINST
DEMOCRATS ON A LOT OF ISSUES,
BUT DEMOCRATS PUSHING A DEFUND
THE POLICE MESSAGE WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS REALLY PALPABLY STRONG
FOR REPUBLICANS, AND NOW BECAUSE
OF A FEW REPUBLICANS, ENOUGH OF
THEM WHO HAVE SAID DEFUND,
DESTROY, AND OTHER THINGS LIKE
THAT, THEY'VE ALLOWED DEMOCRATS
TO GET UP OFF THE MAT AND HAVE
SOME MOMENTUM AS WE START
APPROACHING LABOR DAY IN THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM, AND EVERYTHING
HAS TO BE FOR ENOUGH REPUBLICANS
ALL ABOUT DONALD.
>> RON, THIS HAS TO BE
UPSIDE-DOWN WORLD FOR YOU, AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS STUDIED HISTORY
SO MUCH, THE 1960s, 1970s, SO
NOW HEAR REPUBLICANS BE SO
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT, ANTI-POLICE,
AS DOUG HAS JUST SAID.
TO HEAR THEM SAYING DESTROY THE
FBI.
IT IS A HEAD-SPINNER.
DO YOU THINK THAT IT DOES AFFECT
THE MIDTERMS?
>> WELL, IT'S A HEAD-SPINNER,
ALISYN, IN TERMS OF THE
TRADITIONAL IDEALOGICAL
POSITIONS OF THE PARTIES.
IT'S LESS CONFUSING IF YOU VIEW
IT IN THE CONTEXT OF HOW TRUMP
IS TRANSFORMING THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY INTO SOMETHING MUCH MORE
LIKE WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN TURKEY
OR ITALY, A QUASI-AUTHORITARIAN
PARTY THAT IS COMMITTED, ABOVE
ALL, TO THE RULE OF ITS LEADER.
THE BIG LESSON OF THIS ENTIRE
EPISODE IS BOTH THAT TRUMP FEELS
EVEN MORE UNCONSTRAINED BY RULE,
LAW OR CUSTOM ON THE ARBITRARY
EXERCISE OF PRESIDENTIAL POWER
THAN HE DID BEFORE JANUARY 6th,
AND THAT WHAT WE ARE SEEING FROM
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS OVER
THE PAST WEEK, I THINK, IS A
PRETTY CLEAR SIGNAL THAT IF HE
BECOMES PRESIDENT AGAIN, THEY
WILL BE EVEN LESS INCLINED THAN
THEY WERE THE FIRST TIME TO
IMPOSE ANY CONSTRAINTS ON HIM.
ALL OF THAT IS PART OF THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE PARTY INTO
A VEHICLE OF HIS WILL.
WE'RE SEEING THE SAME THING IN
THESE PRIMARY.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT TOMORROW
NIGHT IN WYOMING.
THE VOTERS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BELIEVE
THAT TRUMP IS KIND OF A TOXIC
INFLUENCE IN AMERICAN LIFE, HAVE
TO ACCEPT THE REALITY AT THIS
POINT THAT THEY ARE THE
SUBORDINATE MINORITY IN THE
PARTY AND THE QUESTION IS, WHAT
DO THEY DO WITH THAT GOING
FORWARD?
>> DOUG, LET ME ASK YOU A
BROADER QUESTION.
WE TALK ABOUT NARRATIVES OF
TRUMP VERSUS THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE GOP.
IS TRUMP THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE GOP?
HE'S THE FORMER PRESIDENT, A
FRONT RUNNER LIKELY FOR THE
NOMINATION IN 2024.
EVERY RACE IS DEFINED WHETHER
YOU WERE ON HIS SIDE OR NOT, AND
MAYBE AFTER TOMORROW EIGHT OF
THE TEN CONGRESSMEN WHO VOTED
AGAINST HIM IN THE IMPEACHMENT
VOTE WILL NOT BE RETURNING NEXT
YEAR, VERY LIKELY.
IS HE NOW THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
YOUR PARTY?
>> YEAH, THERE'S A CASE, REALLY,
OF BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR.
DONALD TRUMP IS EVERYTHING HE
SAID HE WASN'T GOING TO BE.
HE IS THE ESTABLISHMENT NOW.
HE IS THE SWAMP.
IT'S ALL OF THESE THINGS.
I'LL TELL YOU, I TEXTED LAST
WEEK WITH ONE OF THE MEMBERS WHO
WENT UP TO VISIT DONALD TRUMP
LAST WEEK AFTER WE FOUND OUT THE
REVELATIONS ABOUT THE FBI VISIT.
AND I SAID BE VERY CAREFUL HERE
FOR YOUR OWN POLITICAL PURPOSES,
BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW, MORE
BROADLY, BE CAREFUL, BECAUSE WE
KNOW TWO THINGS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
ONE IS WHEN THERE'S A
REVELATION, TWO OR THREE DAYS
LATER WE FIND OUT, GOSH, IT'S
WORSE THAN WE THOUGHT IT WAS,
AND THE OTHER IS POLITICALLY
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T GIVE
POINTS, HE ONLY TAKES THEM AWAY
ONE AT A TIME.
IF YOU STOOD WITH DONALD TRUMP
ON TUESDAY, YOU BETTER HAVE BEEN
WITH HIM ON WEDNESDAY, THURSDAY,
FRIDAY, BECAUSE ANY CRACKS IN
THAT YOU'LL BE HIS NEXT TARGET.
>> RON, I THOUGHT IT WAS SO
INTERESTING WHAT THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY REPUBLICANS TWEETED
OUT ABOUT THE -- WE CAN CALL IT
A RAID ON FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S HOME.
THEY SAID IF THEY CAN DO IT TO A
FORMER PRESIDENT, IMAGINE WHAT
THEY CAN DO TO YOU.
YEAH, IF YOU TAKE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE, THEY CAN DO IT TO REGULAR
PEOPLE.
WE'VE SEEN THAT BEFORE.
>> RIGHT.
LOOK, I MEAN, AGAIN, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THIS VERY
MUCH FITS THE PATTERN THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN EXAMPLES OF THIS ABROAD,
WHERE ANY KIND OF UNEARTHING OF
MISCONDUCT OR ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR
BY THE LEADER IS IMMEDIATELY
TRANSLATED BY THE PARTY INTO AN
ATTACK ON ITS VOTERS.
THIS IS AN ARGUMENT THAT TRUMP
HAS MADE ALL THE WAY THROUGH,
BECAUSE HE HAS ARGUED THAT HE IS
THE HUMAN WALL AGAINST ALL OF
THE CHANGES, CULTURAL,
DEMOGRAPHIC, SOCIAL AND AMERICAN
LIFE THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
HIS VOTERS FEAR AND DISLIKE, AND
THAT ANY TIME ANY QUESTIONS ARE
RAISED ABOUT HIM, WHAT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT IS SILENCING THEM.
AND THAT AT THE MOMENT IS THE
DOMINANT STRAIN, THAT'S THE
DOMINANT FACTION IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IF LIZ CHENEY LOSES
TOMORROW NIGHT, AS EXPECTED.
DOES SHE GO FORWARD INTO THE
2024 REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY, TRYING TO RALLY THE
ONE-FIFTH TO ONE-FOURTH OF
REPUBLICAN VOTERS WHO ARE NOT ON
BOARD WITH THE TRUMP ASSAULT ON
DEMOCRACY, AND WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
IS THERE A PATH FORWARD?
CLEARLY RIGHT NOW THE TRUMP
CRITICS ARE LOSING ALMOST ALL OF
THESE KEY RACES IN MICHIGAN,
ARIZONA, WISCONSIN,
PENNSYLVANIA, ET CETERA.
THE QUESTION IS, CAN THEY BE
ORGANIZED INTO A FORCE THAT
EXERTS ANY INFLUENCE IN THE
PARTY?
BECAUSE EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW IS
POINTING IN THE OTHER DIRECTION
TOWARDS CONTINUED TRANSFORMATI